you
Oh
that is bullshit
which is of hocus-pocus whether we the
national association of registered
critics knock find your movie guilty of
being incredibly dumb therefore you
shall be hanged until hung and your
movie banished into obscurity until
obscure oh come on we weren't that bad
just look what you've done to our youth
hey can I get another kids film about
the awkward team that gets the hot babe
that's every more you've seen this year
yeah I've got babes like them to think
oh you don't need to thank us oh but
you're so bodacious she's actually right
we don't want to entertain you we want
to consume your consumerism the more we
keep you in a formulae bust more likely
you are to watch the things that we put
no effort in thus making math project in
fact when you watch a product to much
you become the product oh that's a black
cat toy they're all the rage though yes
Sailor Moon Sabrina the Teenage Witch
and of course our movie look for an atty
sauce the children can't resist too
strong but joke's on you our movie may
have open number for the box-office but
soon we we're return you mean we'll be
in this tire chick Hollywood will run
out of ice
he'll find comfort from us and soon the
nineties wall will the well that's
impossible
soon pokemons will be popular again Oh
Backstreet Boys ah ah fuck is that
and all of them be exploited by Jimmy
kimber you can't kiss
what depraved time would bring back such
archaic monsters Halloween it's not even
summer yet mmm evil bit too allure a no
this is a Halloween flick we're talking
about hmm ah bogus
and one job you do all these years and I
still fucked it up we'll show them what
a real Halloween classic looks like well
well if there isn't a skeptic in our
mist
aren't you the weird teacher in her
class it keeps obsessing over hocus
pocus we saw your Disney sever review of
it would you care to rethink your
Chicago went up tight shirt and tie
point of view
look watching it once was enough and I
don't get why your class benignly laughs
at stuff even a kindergartner when laugh
at stuff it just so happens that hocus
pocus was supposed to be a Disney
Channel original movie which we all know
right nothing but classics yeah why
would a classroom applaud that teacher
can I interrupt class to announce to
everybody that I'm gonna give this girl
my number last seems like a completely
normal thing to do I will never
understand this fan base evil they two
on the other hand stop that's the
blu-ray of hocus-pocus dude I hid it in
there so nobody would find it uh man the
suburbanite fans are getting weird
there's someone actually plays a blu-ray
of hocus-pocus that means it's popular
enough to bring The Witches back oh and
how would you know about that Gigi
because I've been guarding it you see
I'm a boy that was cursed by them years
ago I haven't told anyone about it until
this day
if you could talk why didn't you talk
all these years don't put it in okay I'm
done with hocus-pocus I'm putting an
evil into
many and Zack is back jack
we are home No bette midler hello
I'm just a Winifred this is sister and
the city and this is sister act now the
fan base just calls her curly huh
look sisters it's 2015 just in time for
the ninety to become nostalgic again no
no no no no there's still plenty of
things today that are totally original
name a recent hit movie goosebumps shit
maximum exes oh and you must be the veg
and prophesize to fail in stopping us
that's an odd thing to focus on he's
like 13
it's a nineties thing we talked about
uncomfortable things without having the
knowledge to talk about them
and now the time has come to control the
minds of this generation by convincing
them that our movie is the greatest
thing ever
No we'll stop you the best way possible
Oh running away like a pussy actually
was a pussy which it back baby wait my
paper says it's been five minutes Oh
Frank and Barry
what was that me every five minutes we
need to distract from the plot and do
some unnecessary monkey usually
misinterpreting things for something
else
Oh what is that Oh do you think it's
some sort of God I think it's so kind of
SH ride or something oh oh that's good
commentary very good Cuddy
come on let's jam captain we really used
to say that this Dragon Ball section is
completely ripping us off
wait what the upbeat music one is dative
anxiety oh it doesn't matter
all 90s kidz films have whimsical
soundtracks and walking through a
neighborhood what else do that halt
Oh
bullies hey Hollywood let's have a boy
oh my god there's no thanks guys I I
don't smoke
Oh what do you help catch us there
Hollywood but boys you just get a nice
jump brownie you mean of these guys
better answer Hollywood can you stop
calling him Hollywood you're the ones
who are Hollywood because Hollywood
obviously wrote for you if you existed
in real life you'll even want being boy
Louise annua
formula you bet if you had I don't
really we should go okay that's a lot
yeah you just humiliated me in front
half the guys at school that wasn't half
the guys at school I was twitter bulk
and tweedle sculpt oh sorry it's just
it's just that it's hard moving into a
new environment you know
yeah I do know you're a growing team
with so many issues that could be
tackled but instead they do the one that
they always do new kid moving into a
neighborhood like that somehow the only
problem any kid ever it's in every 90s
movie everyone doesn't any child
anywhere else have other issues well at
least you don't have a dead parent
that's a popular cliche and look at it
this way kids films in the future are
written a lot better a lot of these 90s
trope don't even exist anymore did you
say goosebumps was number one now James
isn't as bad as you again mr. bus driver
for giving us a ride from us beam sale
gorgeous
you found them gorgeous what can I say
I'm settling any time you wacky broads
wanna indulge my crazy ass fetish
it's alright bye
it's not a speak of him again he wasn't
here yeah let's pick it extreme
old-school style
go ahead budget
oh look at this it's the gravestone of
one of what of Wright's victims
apparently she had a better
interpretation on witches so she
banished would be a triple release and
killed any chances of her being a more
popular American choice wasn't have to
do anything
come on Harriet virgin oh my people up
oh how does fought we need to mug again
well maybe we could do a combing circle
no even the movie came up halfway on
that one
perhaps we could bring in a baby boomer
celebrity that none of the children are
recognized ladies
just to clarify I'm not actually the
devil but I did direct the other sister
so I am to stay in that computer oh we
wouldn't confuse the Lord of Darkness
with an out-of-touch director and read
for James we know it's really you
let me unrealistically invite you in the
hit on you because what can I say I'm
settling oh this calls for extremely
over-the-top hand gestures oh come on e
and I'm completely hijacking the movie
come on come on officer officer the
witches from hocus pocus are trying to
consume everybody's minds and I'm a
virgin
come here
you virgin yeah really
he's 13 what is wrong with everybody
no I should feel bad I'm not even
following in the footsteps of my mom who
dressed up like Madonna this year
well I'd cuff that parents stop Disney
talking about sex they they just don't
know that's okay I'm not even a real cat
what yeah the giveaway is a stupid patch
in my hat dude that's like incredibly
illegal were they gonna do arrest me for
impersonating a police officer no fair
enough
come on buddy it's okay I've got the
patch on my hat oh what a terrible man
marrying your sister was one thing but
then showing us princess diary the royal
engagement is too far look she's what do
people hold Sandy's 300 people at home
watching us right on whoa well then
thank you for that marvelous
introduction I put on nostalgic spell on
you and now you're mine Wow let me -
laughs ha well I have even more crappy
puns alive what is happening right now
on my witch watch time apply today if
you learn how to spell they'll be held
to
this is getting really uncomfortable oh
yeah come to the course no don't fall
under the corporate all number I put on
nostalgic special on you
then your memories my all right mr.
Chisholm makes no common sense but to
laugh because we always use it for a
nice but then started a hunger for a
reason our
don't run
now
when will stay with you till dusk
without your bones this whole thing's a
simpleton where's girl
ouch it
okay surprisingly good number okay so no
touchy
people go sit down he'll know what you
can't spend on gibberish and expect us
to remember it right away yeah you
should have had us for hearse or
something
excuse me excuse me we're doing this all
with Maori hassle yeah uh sure and the
band we're doing this only one go and
quite frankly I think we're killing it
so good for you but we can't even
pronounce half the names we hear on an
anime alright don't line up line up we
have to make it simpler for the
simpletons every single year is the boss
everybody English when they walk in
me
yes
holy shit that was the greatest
performance ever fucking pain whoa
hey everybody just a quick reminder I am
gonna be at Nebraskan this weekend I'll
be there doing panels and signing
autographs and just meeting all the fans
if you like to come by and say hello
definitely check it out hope to see
there the switches my brain watch
everyone else into like in this movie
but they won't yeah we showed her yeah
just two bumps and she went down haha
kind of thought it would be more
exciting than that yeah just two bumps
that's it you think that get like more
of the witches in it be like a big
action scene or something kind of
anticlimactic yeah
why does this have a following again
sister okay we are wasting a lot of time
so what else is new
we must amend ourselves the Halloween
classic indeed
Jesus Christ yes we explain when we fly
now kinda random but it's a nice
experience
extreme suckage they're about to sing
their spell to everyone didn't they
already do that your spell's are kind of
like tax codes they're overly
complicated usually we're done this time
stasia stole this news
my swatch shook his focus lies to our
chokers must watch how his poker lost
watch hocus-pocus and forget about how
awful Sarah Jessica Parker becomes most
watch august boogies nobody you kill
John Lennon and watch Oh get pocus hocus
pocus is damn crazy
oh no we're too late they're already
hypnotized by the Phils manipulative
pandering
we're closed now we can sell them our
laziness over and elder with a new
transformers baby oh my gosh this is so
lame and I remember can you believe we
got suckered into this as children women
you're you're making fun of it both yeah
it's a cheesy 90s movie man yeah it's
fun but we know it's bad seriously
you you mean you don't see us as
legitimately great film well you're like
McDonald's we know there's better stuff
out there but yeah so you don't admire
the half-assed messages or uncomfortable
sex jokes well yeah we're nostalgic but
we're not stupid yeah we just like
watching three crazy-ass old ladies
telling desperate jokes that's Brett
it's like if the Golden Girls were goth
girls huh maybe it was a little harder
at than I originally should have been I
mean it's not a clever film at all but
if people are really looking past the
bad stuff I guess there's a few good
things you can admire the CG mixing with
the practical effects that was pretty
good visually it is interesting and in
all honesty the three actresses playing
the witches they are kind of
entertaining I mean they never had
anything funny to say ever but you can
tell they're putting their all in every
scene I mean every single time they're
on they're doing something waving hands
spinning around doing a day as they're
just always on you can tell they're
having a blast while filming it and yeah
maybe a little bit that fun is kind of
infectious even the virgin shaming
really isn't as bad as I remember it so
God in a strange way this movie really
is the ultimate Halloween guilty
pleasure Vic might tell a frog you
horse's ass we could have made a bundle
with such a little effort now because of
people like you people want never
writing that's how we got to show you
what these wicked bitches from the West
can do back off Mars Attacks I still got
ace up my sleeve
hey tell us that it turns out this Evil
Dead 2 DVD is a pretty good recreation
of the Necronomicon and it's frightfully
good at bringing back the dead
ishka bible is kaput here's a real wish
to take care of you
good character iron good riding I
treated kids like they were smart and I
said no printer
the piss on their corpses King shut up
you know me I am you probably did
oh yeah I just I think I think we won I
think we want justice yes yes we'd get
away
please get away I think we want I think
we got this we are run the sisters we
are harmless yes we want this one
your lust for blood is legendary just
remember anyone says they're better with
me oh so Kiki what took you so long
sorry I had to wait 20 years for a
virgin man it's a good thing I randomly
showed you that grave earlier right can
you imagine that just gave birth to a
zombie who contributed nothing to the
story at all but just walked around in
silence the whole time following us even
though he didn't like following the
witch's orders but he did it anyway
leading to a scene where he cuts open
the stitches to absolutely say nothing
just shout obscenities and then when
it's all done he just goes back in his
grave and he was a totally absolutely
pointless character that'd be stupid
that'd be relative oh let's see who this
which really is Odia Isaac invalid guy
from children of the corn but why we
were tempted to brainwash the minds of
the youth but I realize now the only
evil entity that truly has control of
every child's brain is Disney well wait
who are you - then wait guessers at a
Renaissance Faire yeah I don't see
myself having much of a good morrow
Camela kind we must prepare for tomorrow
enough why Isaac what we gonna do
tomorrow night the same thing we do
every night Marik I try to take over to
win with
if I can the children of the corn corn
corn corn corn
I just don't know critic I don't think
I'll fit too well in this time period
are you kidding everybody in this
generation is trying to get your
generation back besides I think there's
a few people you can bond with dude was
that great where you going
this has been one fucking weird
nostalgia wean I think it's time I
returned to something more familiar oh
you mean like 90 shows something like
that
the
you
sup witches
everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and got a real lovely
one this week
this is Give Kids the World org this is
a place where children with terminal
illnesses can stay while visiting their
favorite attractions in Orlando that
includes SeaWorld and Disney World and
Universal all those great places but the
wonderful thing about it is that the
resort itself is almost like a mini
amusement park if the children aren't
feeling well and can't go to one of the
attractions they bring the attractions
to them there's people in costumes
there's incredible food there's all
sorts of little rides there's wonderful
visuals all over the place and the
wonderful thing about is that it doesn't
cause the families of thing it's run
totally by volunteers and by people who
really care about giving these children
a wonderful day a wonderful week that'll
last them the rest of their lives if you
go to the YouTube channel and you see
all the videos of children having such a
phenomenal time and all the adults who
are sharing so much with them going that
extra mile trying to give them a warm
wonderful place where they can just feel
like a kid again
it melts your heart every time and one
of the ways it sticks around it can grow
even stronger is from your support this
is definitely a good cause you can go
check out the videos yourself and see
the wonderful things that they're doing
so if you get a little extra time a
little extra change a little extra
anything please please definitely go
check
these are children that deserve
wonderful moments and you can help give
those wonderful moments too